[Music]
first up my flavor packed lamb with
fried bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so this lamb dish proves that
you don't have to spend a fortune to
create delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just here because you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice added
sweet flavor
just take your knife cut through each
end this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks evenly and colors beautifully salt
and pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper
and just pat that down the pan's just
under smoke on the outside now put the
oil in get that pan really nice and hot
because this is a cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of impart a lot of
flavor
that's the noise you want to hear you
can't hear that noise don't drop the
steak in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs lift up
a bit of fat around the back that's the
top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
turn it
that color over
beautiful
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear
all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and base
and basting the lamb steak just means
you're sort of adding all that nice
scented
garlic olive oil back into the lamb
now take the lamb out let the lamb rest
now
for the perfect
rustic crouton so this bread's quite
firm a couple of days old
just slice it straight down the center
dice it up
put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking i'm
gonna make the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
look at that beautiful into the pest and
water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some capers
they're little baby cats very sweet
now
just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible next some dijon
mustard
a nice teaspoon and a half in a little
bit of red wine vinegar two tablespoons
and then our extra virgin olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there got a nice
roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamb some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley
delicious flavor parsley in
nice
[Music]
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk out not too hard i don't
want them dry
and in
and then just fry them
and the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor
that's the color i want
nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit of kitchen roll onto the
board out
[Music]
plate them just take this amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it
get those croutons
listen to them
like little boulders hitting the play
the lamb
sit that on
next one
on
the rest of the croutons
on
now use all those little bits
and my chef in paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on
and then just
drop that sauce
on all those little bits
of the lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
into the premier league of dishes
[Music]
we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
char grilled broccoli and bulgur wheat
salad
to cook the bulgur wheat just simmer
until tender then drain
to give the broccoli a char grilled
flavor simply cook with salt in a hot
dry pan until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mixed together harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and burger wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salad's done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes
a lot a lot on a scale of one to ten
ten okay these lamb chops are gonna be
delicious
first i'm gonna marinate them i'll start
putting the spices in yeah first one
coriander coriander good so a teaspoon
of coriander seeds in a little touch of
what's that human human well done cumin
in one of daddy's favorites
turmeric tuna a teaspoon of that in
there
now
a little touch
of salt
and then i want you to start grinding
that down while i get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix
please for daddy
that looks amazing after that get the
garlic lay it flat
and look
it almost purees the garlic so we get a
nice paste see underneath sorry about
dirting your nails
it's okay
i just smell of garlic now nothing wrong
with that
the more you smell of garlic
the less the boys are gonna date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of
spicy
and fruity now get the ginger and do
exactly the same with ginger when you
grate it like this it turns into the
most amazing
ginger puree off you're dying
come on holly put some muscle into it
good good
nice see all that there you got the back
of the knife
now i'm gonna drizzle some olive oil in
there okay and you bring that together
as a paste for daddy there you go
stuck on no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now that smells incredible that
is a delicious paste
so i'm gonna tip
all that marinade on
to the lamb
and then i want you
to rub it all in to those lamb chops
then we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look you get them in there then you
rub
all that marinade
the flavor inside these chops come on
holly how'd you
come on
your jumper's fine
just
smell that
nice and fresh
and the earlier you do this the better
the turmeric is starting to stain
the lamb chops they're not even cooked
yet yet they smell delicious yeah
what do you like honestly oh my nails
oh my nails delicious after marinating
from 10 minutes to overnight but if you
can't wait to get your hands on them you
can grill the chops straight away gas
nice and high and grilling them
is going to make them slightly healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you fit more in the
pan that's right what i want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
see
now we're going to cook them
three sides
one side up flip it and then on the back
see this bit here yeah i'm gonna grill
it on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please damn it
nice
some fresh mint
i want you to pick
the mint
please and give it a little chop and mix
it in with a yogurt smells amazing
doesn't it
so yogurt
in
chop up
the mint please
have a
look at the color
of the lamb
beautiful
that holds so nice doesn't it
how nice
are they
they smell incredible grilling them this
way they cook so much quicker
okay it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful excited yes barry
good eric and megan will like those i
hope so
[Music]
see what i'm doing i'm standing the
chops up yeah
yeah we're not going to dry out this way
is that chopped enough try a bit more
that's fine and then mix it
into the yogurt please darling this
isn't too hard is it dad not at all my
darling
how would you know when they're done
nice and pink three and a half to four
minutes each side
medium
six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your landmine darling
medium rare that's what i always go for
a lamb cutlet at its best
will be medium red off with the gas
okay
it's got a lovely lovely flavor
okay
look at that
wow
i'm in heaven
[Music]
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work really well so don't
be precious this is gutsy cooking at its
absolute best
[Music]
these are lamb breasts
a beautiful cheap cut and it's sort of
tucked alongside the rib they've been
boned out the skin has been taken off
i'm going to roll them stuff them and
braise them braising simply means
cooking in liquid on a low heat making
the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
season
season them both sides inside and out
really important
it doesn't look like a real weighty
dense cut of meat but once it's
beautifully slow braised it's just like
melting lamb it's incredible
i'm gonna season the breasts with some
dried oregano
put a heat in there
some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
got some amazing
salty anchovies in there now they almost
melt inside the lamb
so the balance of flavors work
beautifully
now pull it down
towards you
and roll that nice and tightly
that's what i'm looking for
string i just need to tie them
three times one at each end and one in
the middle
i fell in love with this dish years ago
when i first started working in paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
get that oil nice and hot
lamb in
really important to get some nice color
on there
whilst they're browning
slice the onion
the lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours
so don't slice the onions too thinly
otherwise they'll burn garlic and leave
whole i've got a color on them look at
that
beautiful
take them out
onions in and garlic straight in lovely
[Music]
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans
why
all the goodness is in that one
pan a few chili seeds in there
oregano
nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there i'm gonna
do the onions what i did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding in the bottom of the
pan they get nice and crispy
next my black olives
now
white wine
mmm
bring that up to the boil
delays in the pan as well
rinsing the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now where that tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
those plum tomatoes
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Applause]
that's nice
lid on
into the oven
170
two and a half hours and forget about it
whoa
beautiful
all that has reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
has kept its color look at that it's
braised beautifully
very carefully
get your little bits there
slice
off pull off the little bits of string
this is why i get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
i can smell the
lemon it's hard to believe when you
slice through the center there that that
is a very cheap
cut of meat i'm salivating
i love this i mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
amazing
great sauce
take
your lamp sort of just
sit it on
it looks incredible
[Music]
and that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]
marinating the lamb first
chilis we're gonna use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there
cooking
for up to three hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out
is extraordinary they release a little
oil as well and helps to tenderize the
lamb a touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it sliced
secret slicing vegetables from braising
is not getting too thin you slice the
onions too thin they burn you've got
that horrible char taste on that slow
braised braising it's just a chef's term
that means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat incredibly moist
and beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil
lamb in hold the bone
because you're in control then into the
pan
i want that white fat
to start rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
chilies
cinnamon
in
mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're
getting the color on the lamb which
washes off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat
on top of the vegetables
now just glaze the pan with red wine
this glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish
always delays
then bring to the boil and cook for
about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and incredibly tender grab it by
the the shank roll around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce nice
beautiful
just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow
and there you go a very spicy delicious
melting of the mouth
lamb shank amazing
[Music]
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of rolls-royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing to an absolute tea for
the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
just salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamb
now we've got the color on those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts
and that helps to give a bit of a
texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in
and just lay the spinach over the pine
nuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
going to condense and disappear almost
instantly
[Music]
there's so much more flavor in spinach
when you saute it as opposed to steaming
it or boiling it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs crumpled feta over the
spinach
feta cheese adds a beautifully salty
sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings that stuffing together
now
open up
the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
soon
sumac is a wonderful lemony spice that
goes brilliantly with lamb and you can
get it in most big supermarkets and it
sort of cuts through that
thick rich sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon
if you're preparing this for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's gonna
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of
increase that beautiful tunnel
and then from there
over there
and bring that
towards you
and then roll
like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now
to tie it first off
around the side
and don't worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops
i got two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing out of the lamb when it's in
the oven
nice
now we'll just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it very nicely colored
none of your stuffing is coming out of
the sides really important
look at that color beautiful does kick
start the roasting process
gas off
into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tail the cucumber
peel it
cut the cucumber
into three
and just core taking out all that it's
just sort of watery seedy and
it spoils the flavor slice the cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
gonna dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt a couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint
dressing a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested carefully take off the
string
and then just gently pull them back
straight to the edge knife that's going
to cut through that crispy fat on the
outside instantly
i tied it purposely so i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay
and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing meats
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast